SUPPORT.  STAPLES CE BEACH. EXE.
YOU CAN BE CREATIVE.
IF YOU'RE TO THE GOINGIAFALLO.
BACK TO NEUTRAL FOOUJS DEVILS.
EVENT FIRST
KALIYEV EASIER, THTH
IAFALLO  TO ON THE POWER PLAY.
HONESTESLY I DON'T MIND THEIR67
>> HE WAS A ONE D NAVIGATES NEU
CAGGIULA ONE TIMER BYPASS, COUNT
BLOCKEDBJORK.
THE SABRES DUMP IT ALL THE WAY
DOWN.
SO
THE KINGS HOW QUICKLY THEY'RE
MAKING DECISIONS IN THIS GAMEHE
STICK OUT OF PLAY.
>> CHANCE AGAIN FOR THE KINGS.
IT'S GOOD THE
PUCK IN THE CORNERERONATHAN QUI
VINNY HINOSTROZA.
>> IT TURNED AWAY BY
TOKARSKI.  SITUATIONSS LEMIEUX
CHIRPINGHAT COULD HAVE BEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY IS BROKEN UP.
>> PERFECT TIMING POWER PLAY.
>> AS MUCH AS SKILL WAS ABOUT T
SECOND INTERMISSION POWER PLAY
YOU MOVE IT AROUND WITH A COUPLE
OF TOKARSKI
FOR THE
MAATTAA, RUOTSALAINEN, UP A
EXPLANATION.
.
TURNOVER TWO THREE
SHIFTS AGO IS WEARING DOWN THE
SABRES.
THEY'RE STARTING TONZE KOPITAR
GOAL.  OFF.
>> THAT'S ALL THEY'LL GET. THIS
BUT YOU SEE THE PUCK